I am Dion Robert Bowen reporter at the
Wall Street Journal I know you know
something a little different those of
you who've been watching Market takes we
are in the brand new studio but we are
still bringing you the same live fly
Market takes appreciate you being with
us I know you could have been anywhere
in the world but you're here with me and
you know what I appreciate that we are
talking about inflation today we are
digging into the CPI Consumer Price
Index inflation report that just came
out this morning talking about what
happened in August we are going to talk
about of course what the report showed
and how that compared to expectations
I'm going to give you some major
takeaways from this report uh we're also
going to talk of course about the market
reaction what happened with stocks bonds
Commodities I really want to talk about
the big picture reaction where we are
right now in the markets rather than
just the response to today's uh report
we're also of course going to talk about
how this CPI report influences or or
effects the FED in their decision
they're going to be meeting a week from
today we'll be right here on Market
takes at 4 pm Eastern breaking that
meeting down for you so be sure and be
with us then but we'll be talking about
how this report affects the fed's
decision on about a week from now or
exactly a week from now and then of
course we'll be talking about what comes
next because we are always looking
forward here on Market takes even though
it is backward looking data so let's get
into it the CPI report for August showed
3.7 or inflation Rose to 3.7 percent
rate year over year let's throw a chart
up here on your screen so you can see
just what we're talking about now if we
go back we're going back to January 2022
here and you see inflation Rises up
until June and then it comes back down
and hit that 9.1 percent rate in June of
2022 and then for 12 months straight
inflation just goes down down you see it
there until June of 2023 inflation and
then July 2023 we saw inflation pick
back up and then in August 2023 which is
the report that we just got we saw
inflation rise even higher so going from
three percent in June 3.2 percent in
July 3.7 percent in August so we are
seeing right now inflation sort of work
backwards and move away from what the
Federal Reserve wants and the goals
that's important and that matters
because the FED really is driving this
economy has been driving this economy
for a long time and as they raise rates
it gets harder for the economy to grow
gets harder for businesses to grow for
folks consumers to get more money to
borrow to do things they want to do so
as inflation picks back up the Federal
Reserve is definitely watching and as
you see their inflation definitely
picking up uh Rose 0.6 month over month
and again that was right on target but
this 3.7 inflation to this 3.7 reading
we got for inflation a little bit above
expectations just a tad bit so this was
priced in this big this pickup that
you're seeing there the increase that's
priced in it doesn't mean the market
isn't going to react though so this
chart just illustrating this longer run
theme of inflation coming down and then
picking back up over the last few months
you've got to know what's going going on
with inflation because inflation really
is driving everything right now so like
I said a little bit higher than
expectations economists had predicted
3.6 year-over-year inflation 0.6 month
over month uh so we got a little bit
higher than that but not much uh core
CPI let's talk about that let's talk
about when we strip out those volatile
food and energy prices what we get I
want to put another chart up here on
your screen just give you an idea of
what we're seeing from the core numbers
so there you've seen that had been a
little stickier we had seen inflation
sticking above five percent even after
overall inflation had fallen down to
four percent even close to three we had
seen that core prices holding up well
now we're starting to see those come
down and this is important because this
is what the FED really focuses on fed
knows they can't do all that much about
the price of food the price of oil the
price of gas at the pump but what they
can control is what core is showing us a
lot of things with regard to housing
regard to the labor market that's where
this is and this is showing it's higher
than overall CPI we got a 4.3 rating in
August or 4.5 three percent reading in
August I should say but it is coming
down moving in the right direction month
over month though it did rise a little
bit more than expected 0.3 percent and
this chart just illustrating you know
the way that core CPI is held up but is
now coming down in the way the FED wants
it to and that's good news for folks who
are watching the FED saying oh no we
hope they don't raise rates anymore this
year we'll talk we'll talk more about
that in just a second so let's talk
about the major takeaways from this
report today's report tells us that the
CPI headline inflation number is rising
but that's largely because of gas prices
when we dig into the report we can see
that the largest contributor was the
gasoline index the Bureau of Labor
Statistics actually saying that gasoline
accounted for 50 so half of the overall
increase in inflation that we saw last
month was due to gas prices and we saw a
huge pickup when we look at the numbers
in terms of month over month for the
pickup in gasoline oil energy all those
things and this was a an increase month
over month of 10.6 percent that is a
huge Blockbuster blowout number when it
comes to gasoline or any particular
index any particular portion of the CPI
10.6 was the biggest increase in the
overall CPI to give you an idea of how
big that is things tend to rise month
over month again I said CPI Rose 0.6
overall month over month well it Rose
10.6 percent in terms of gasoline the
gasoline index now that's good news and
it's bad news the good news is this was
expected we've seen gas prices rising
we've seen those prices at the pump
Rising we've seen those oil prices
rising in the markets so this was
expected no one was caught off guard by
this big rise in gas
but the bad news is because we've seen
oil prices rise continuing into
September we will likely see inflation
rise up again on that headline level for
September that means inflation could
start pushing back towards four percent
now obviously we don't know it's
September 13th right now but the theme
that we have seen and we're going to
look at the markets in a sec I'll show
you just what I'm talking about I think
we've seen this for higher gas prices
oil prices and that's all factoring into
inflation inflation expectations oil
prices also go into everything because
when you're getting something odds art
was delivered on a truck well that
diesel fuel charge and the prices that
you know anyone who's delivering items
to your store anyone who's driving
around for their job anyone who's
getting to work anyone who's powering a
building those things are all based on
fossil fuels oil gas the prices all come
back to there so the prices of goods and
services are likely to be going up
because those gas prices go up and folks
have to keep raising prices now the FED
is not in control of oil so when it
comes to the Federal Reserve it's a good
news sort of bad news situation for them
because they say okay well gas prices
might come down we don't know we've got
to focus on the core index and that's
coming down the way they want it to
similarly good news about the core CPI
good news is it was near expectations
around point three percent that's pretty
low and again moving in the right
direction core continues to decrease and
housing costs are starting to come down
remember housing last month was the
biggest contributor to overall inflation
accounted for 90 percent of the increase
90 so this month it's now oil and gas
and gasoline index that's leading things
housing is is retreating in terms of the
role that is playing in pushing up
inflation that's definitely a good thing
um the bad news is core was higher than
expected despite the fact that most of
the increase was from food and energy so
you've still got core being not only
higher than CPI but higher on a month
over month level than what was expected
that's just telling us that inflation is
being pushed up by a lot of different
things right now given that the pce the
fed's favored measure of inflation also
Rose last month we can expect to see
another increase increasing that and we
can expect to kind of see that the trend
for inflation right now is moving back
up instead of down that's not what the
FED wants that's not necessarily good
news it's not terrible news but it's not
great news it's not something that's
going to get investors really up and
excited and you know cheering and saying
hey the fed's done they're gonna have to
cut rates soon that's not what we're
seeing keep in mind interest rates are
very high right now we are at levels
that have historically led to recessions
that have historically led to a
struggling economy the economy overall
is still pretty good but right now where
we are we don't really want to move
higher because that inflation forces the
fed's hand so we're not there yet but we
aren't at a place where we can say a
kind of mission accomplished
um obviously like I said the biggest
reason for the increase the increase gas
and oil in addition to the big 10.6
month-over-month increase in gas in the
gasoline index fuel oil Rose nine
percent and energy Commodities Rose ten
and a half percent most of the other
increases to the CPI or
0.1.2.4 or something like that some
things like used cars and trucks even
decline but then you you look at that
oil and gas component it's 10 9 10.5
energy overall was 5.6 that's the only
place in the CPI that you see those
numbers so again big part of this was
oil and gas and we know that's moving up
we also know that's something that
consumers notice and that affects
inflation expectations and as folks as
folks expect inflation to rise they
start demanding more wage increases they
start being okay with paying more money
for items and that pushes inflation up
because we know those corporations love
to raise prices and if folks have in
their mind okay inflation's going up
they don't sort of bulk and step back
when they see prices going up they just
say oh well that's how it goes and they
pay it and that pushes inflation up even
further Energy prices one thing I want
to talk about
is where we are and why we're seeing
this now a big piece of this is the way
Energy prices moved Energy prices picked
up in a big way and peaked kind of in
the summer of 2022. then they started
going down so what we're comparing to
when we look at this report is where
Energy prices were a year ago well they
were lower they were actually higher a
year ago than they are now but we have
seen a consistent increase in Energy
prices in gasoline prices in oil prices
and what we're going to start doing is
as we move further into Autumn and into
the winter we're going to start
comparing to energy price increases that
were lower so keep in mind the bases the
base was here when we were in June July
uh really going back to May right now
the base has been coming down so as we
as oil prices stay elevated we're
comparing to Energy prices when they
were lower and that's going to start
moving inflation higher if Energy prices
stay where they are if oil prices stay
where they are right now when we look
out at the FED fund Futures Market
investors are still saying this doesn't
change anything about September they're
still not sure about the rest of the
year there's about a 50 50 chance the
FED raises rates one more time this year
but investors not convinced that this
moves the FED at all they're pretty
locked in for no rate increase this
month they're meeting next month but or
sorry they're meeting next week but keep
in mind that they're going to Signal
what comes next they release the summary
of economic projections and the Dot Plot
that's going to tell us how they view
the economy going forward and that's
what you're going to want to focus on
for that meeting let's take a look at
what's going on in markets because I
think the action in markets right now is
very interesting you're seeing the Dow
right now up just hanging on to being
positive in the green the s p and the
NASDAQ though have turned negative we
saw after this report came out the the
indexes moved a little higher you see
the NASDAQ there moving decidedly
negative investors have kind of wrapped
their heads around this they're saying
oh we don't really like this let's take
a look at what's going on in bonds the
uh the Government Bond is like really
haven't moved just seeing the 30 year
the 10-year all these notes across the
board really little change you saw a bit
of a move from the 10-year note right
after that CPI report came out moving
higher now it's moving lower kind of
doing the same thing as the stock market
you're seeing a similar move from the
two-year which is the most aligned with
what people expect from the Federal
Reserve you saw a big spike initially
after the report came out and now you're
seeing a move lower seeing a little bit
of consolidation not much to talk about
here in currencies the euro is picking
up is dropping a little bit so you're
seeing the dollar increase when we look
down here on the dollar Index the US
dollar Index up just a little bit the
wsj and the wsj dollar Index which
compares the dollar to come come at
currencies excuse me like the Chinese
Yuan
the Brazilian real Mexican peso things
like that and and those broader
currencies in Europe you're seeing that
pick up a little bit and that move
against the euro is pretty significant I
want to talk to you about Commodities I
want to talk especially about oil as we
look on this year-to-date oil chart
you're seeing exactly what I was talking
about right really going back to July
you see oil was down there about 67 now
we are up here around 90 and that's on
WTI when you look at Brent crude oil
that's even more pronounced we are up
above 90 a barrel and that's a big
difference from where we were just in
July down there around 70 dollars a
barrel this is a big spike price spike
and you can just really see that and
this is what inflation this is what the
CPI report is showing is this big spike
right here in oil prices almost all that
is being factored into CPI so again the
market just showing us the market
illustrating what's going on in terms of
overall inflation just as that gasoline
that oil price is hiking and picking up
well that's what we're seeing with
overall inflation there's lots to
inflation more than just oil so that's
what's kind of holding it down but we
are seeing oil prices pick back up and
that is bringing inflation up with it
now how does this influence the fed well
the FED is looking a little split in
terms of what they want to do you've got
a portion of the committee that really
is committed to hey you know we haven't
done enough on inflation and those folks
when they see this report they're going
to say hey inflation's rising up higher
we really need to stay strong we need to
make sure and let the market know that
we are committed to two percent
inflation not two and a half not three
we want two and we need to hammer that
home
then you've got another part of the FED
another group within the fed that's
saying Hey listen I'm seeing uh consumer
delinquencies Rising I'm seeing credit
card delinquencies Rising I'm seeing
this jobs rate slow down we're seeing
lots of signs of stress within the
economy uh folks can't get bank loans as
readily as they could before folks are
having a hard time paying for things
we're seeing discount stores saying that
people are struggling they're not making
as much money we need to slow down we
might have raised rates too high already
and we need to really commit to backing
off and easing off and that's the the
big split that we're seeing at the
Federal Reserve I think this report
because you saw overall inflation pick
up but you saw core inflation kind of
pull down it gives both camps a little
bit of ammo and we might see a dissent
at next week's fed meeting I think
really the interesting thing is going to
be November and December I think really
the FED is in line to not move rates at
this meeting I think everyone will agree
but going forward into November and
December you could start to see some
dissents as this new fed board this is a
very unique diverse fed board it's got
labor economists it's got folks who are
focused on different segments of the
economy than the FED has typically and
historically been focused on we will get
the Dot Plot to summary of economic
projections and I think you'll see a lot
of difference in terms of what certain
people in the FED are thinking and when
other people in the FED are thinking and
this report will really be the engine
that fires a lot of that disagreement a
lot of that Discord that I think you
look to see
um big picture takeaway from this report
is inflation is not dead when those oil
prices are spiking up like they have
combining with a housing market that is
just not falling apart because there's
so much demand as we've talked about
here on Market takes a number of times
we are seeing inflation just not going
away and that looks to be what this CPI
report has showed us oil obviously is
driving inflation higher housing's still
playing a role all those things are
keeping inflation elevated above where
the FED wants it to be but it is coming
down on the core level so again we're
going to see what happens and how the
Federal and how the Federal Reserve
makes its mind up about this data anyway
man what comes next we've got the
leading economic indicators report out
tomorrow that's on Thursday and the U.S
menuing manufacturing and services PMI
reports out on Friday but of course
we'll be right here 4 pm Eastern on
Market takes on Wednesday September 20th
breaking down the FED meeting listen I'm
Dion Robert Bowen reporter at the Wall
Street Journal this has been mark it
takes thank you so much for joining us
and I hope you'll be back when we do it
again next time